[Music]
the crowds were out for Prince Harry and
Megan back on royal duties and only just
home from their family break in Canada
stepping in front of the cameras they
would have known this announcement was
coming in an extraordinary statement the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex said after
many months of reflection and internal
discussions we've chosen to make a
transition this year in starting to
carve out a progressive new role within
this institution we intend to step back
as senior members of the royal family
and work to become financially
independent while continuing to fully
support Her Majesty the Queen we now
plan to balance our time between the
United Kingdom and North America
continuing to honor our duty to the
Queen the Commonwealth and our patronage
'as this geographic balance will enable
us to raise our son with an appreciation
for the royal tradition into which he
was born
while also providing our family with the
space to focus on the next chapter
including the launch of our new
charitable entity their family time in
Canada where this photo of Harry and a
month-old art she was taken had
obviously given them thinking space to
make what is a monumental decision for
such high-profile members of the royal
family the Queen will be very upset and
I think that she possibly doesn't have
really the courage or the willpower to
deal with these sort of issues at her
age but you know Harry is an individual
who can make his choice the fact he's
now six in-line mean that he doesn't go
to all these state events as he would do
if he was higher up a statement from the
palace reflecting on what other family
members knew and what they didn't said
that discussions with the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex are at an early stage
adding we understand their desire to
take a different approach these are
complicated issues that will take time
to work through the past 12 months have
had their challenges there was the
global media interest around the arrival
of their son Archie the couple have also
faced significant criticism for the two
million pound refurbishment of their
family home and fees in private jets on
their summer holidays
at the end of their successful tour of
Africa it became clear Prince Harry had
had enough announcing they were taking
legal action against the men on Sunday
and releasing a statement that was a
stinging attack against the wider press
the prince showing he would do anything
to protect his wife and family
we will firmly stand up for what we
believe we are fortunate enough to have
a position that gives us amazing
opportunities and we linking everything
that we can to play our part in building
a better world the excitement about what
this modern and diverse couple meant for
the Royals was enormous
but rumors were split between Prince
William and Prince Harry that were then
exacerbated by the announcement that
they were splitting their charitable
foundation had appeared to show that
this was a couple who at times were
struggling with what was expected of
them pictures released during Christmas
of the Queen and her three heirs may
suggest the pressure was off for Harry
and Megan but it's clear the decision to
release this statement and carve out a
new path was made by the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex alone in the family
themselves are still coming to terms
with what exactly it all means we add on
Mills Sky News